so we're asked to find the sum of the
first 50 terms of this series and you
might immediately recognize that it is a
geometric series when we go from one
term to the next what are we doing well
we're multiplying by ten elevenths to go
from one to ten elevenths you multiply
by 10 over 11 then you multiply by 10
over 11 so 10 11 10 over 11 again and we
keep doing this and we want to find the
first 50 terms of it so we can apply
the formula we derived for the sum of a
finite geometric series and that tells
us that the sum of let's say in this
case the first 50 terms actually let me
do it down here
so the sum
the sum
of the first 50 terms is going to be
equal to the first term
which is 1 so it's going to be 1 times
1 minus let me do that in a different
color
1 times
1 minus the common ratio so the common
ratio here is 10 11
10 11
to the 50th power to the power of how
many terms we have
all of that over 1 minus our common
ratio
and so i'm not going to solve it
completely but we can simplify this a
little bit this is going to be 1 minus
and let me put parentheses here just to
make sure we're not just taking the 10
to the 50th power so 1 minus 10
11
to the 50th power
over
this is 11 11 minus 10 11 is over 1 over
11. and so this is the same thing as
multiplying the numerator by 11. so this
is going to be equal to
11
times 1 minus
10
11
to the 50th power and you could try to
simplify this even more but this gets us
pretty far at this point it is just
arithmetic
let's do another one of these this is
kind of fun
so this is more clearly a geometric
series
and let's just first think about how
many terms we're going to take the sum
of you might be tempted to say okay
we're taking to the 79th power there
must be 79 terms here but be very
careful because the first term is when
we're taking things to the zeroth power
we're taking 0.99 to the zeroth power
the the second term is where we're
taking it to the first power the third
term is where we're taking it to the
second power the fourth term is where
we're taking it to the third power so on
and so forth so this right over here
is the 80th
the 80th term 80th
term
so we want to find
s
sub 80
and so this is going to be equal to our
first
our first term is going to be 1
times
1 minus our common ratio
to the 80th power
to the 80th power
all over and i'm leaving a blank because
we still need to figure out our common
ratio all over 1 minus our common ratio
so at first you might say well maybe the
common ratio here is 0.99
but notice we have a change in sign here
and the key thing is to say well to go
from one term to the next what are we
multiplying by
well to go from
the first term to the second term we
multiply by negative
0.99
and then
so we're multiplying by negative 0.99
now to go to the next term we're again
multiplying by negative 0.99
so the comp the the
the common ratio is not positive 0.99
but negative 0
negative 0.99 so let me write that
negative
0.99
and of course that is going to be to the
80th power all over 1 minus negative
0.99
and so we could simplify this a little
bit this is all going to be equal to
well that one we don't have to worry too
much about that and so this is going to
be 1
minus so
negative 0.99 to the 80th power actually
put parentheses there to make sure we're
we are taking the negative
0.99 to the 80th power
well we're taking it to an even power so
it's going to be positive so that's
going to be the same thing as 0.99
to the 80th power
and all of that over
well subtracting a negative that's just
going to be adding the positive so all
of that over 1.99
and we could attempt to simplify it more
but
if we had a calculator we could actually
find this this exact value or our close
value actually most most calculators
don't give you the exact value when you
take something to the 80th power but
this is this is what that sum is going
to be
let's do one more of these
all right so here we have a series
defined recursively and so it's useful
to just think about what it would
actually look like so the first term is
10
and then the next term
so the second term a sub 2 is equal to a
sub 1 times 9 10
right so the next term is going to be
the previous term times 9 10. so it's
going to be 10
times 9 over 10 and then the next term
is going to be that times is going to be
the second term the third term is the
second term times nine tenths so ten
times nine over ten
nine over ten squared and the way it's
written right now we don't i haven't
written it as a finite
geometric series so let's say we want to
take the sum let's say we want the sum
of first
first i don't know 30 terms
sum of first 30 terms so what will this
be well we're going to take s sub 1
s
sub
30 i don't know why i wrote 10 s sub 30.
the sum of the first 30 terms is going
to be equal to the first term we've done
this before the first term
times 1 minus the common ratio 1 minus
the common ratio to the 30th power
all of that over 1 minus the
common ratio
and let's see we could 1 minus 9 10 this
is 1 10 right over here you divide by 1
10. that's the same thing as multiplying
by 100 so this is going to be 100 times
1 minus 9
10
to the
well let me write it this way 9 10
to the 30th power
and actually these parentheses you
always want to
put parentheses there just make sure we
see that we're talking about the 9 and
the 10 or the 9 tenths the whole thing
to the 30th power not just the 9. so
there
there you go did i yep there you go
we're done